so
one guy that talks about exponential
functions a lot is elon musk uh he seems
to internalize this kind of
way of exponential thinking
he calls the first principles thinking
so to kind of yeah
going to the basics asking the question
like what were the assumptions of the
past how can
how can we throw them out the window how
can we do this 10x much more efficiently
and constantly practicing that process
and also
using that kind of thinking to estimate
sort of uh when you know create
deadlines and estimate when you'll be
able to deliver
on some of these technologies now
it it often gets him in trouble because
he
overestimates like he uh he doesn't
meet the initial estimates of the
deadlines but he
seems to deliver late
but deliver right and which is kind of
an interesting like what are your
thoughts about this whole well no i i i
think
we can all learn from elon i think going
to first principles i talked about two
ways of of
getting more of a grip on the
exponential function and one of them
just comes from first principles you
know if you understand the math of it
you can see what's going to happen and
even if it seems counterintuitive
that a couple of dozen of covid cases
could become
thousands or tens or hundreds of
thousands of them in a month
um it makes sense once you just do the
math um
and i think elon tries to do that a lot
i you know at ferris i think he also
benefits from hanging out in silicon
valley
and he's experienced it in a lot of
different applications so you know
it's not as much of a shock to him
anymore but that's uh that's something
we can all learn from
i in my own life i remember one of my
first experiences
um really seeing it was when i was a
grad student and my
my advisor asked me to plot the growth
of computer power in the us economy
in different industries and there are
all these you know exponentially growing
curves and i was like holy [ __ ] look at
this each
in each industry it was just taking off
and you know
you have to be a rocket scientist to
extend that and say wow this means that
this was in the late 80s and early 90s
that you know if it goes anything like
that
we're going to have orders of magnitude
more computer power than we did at that
time and
of course we do
you